やアイコン実は外れ雪をでえっと錦堂道とイベントの関係で3日間プレで稼働してい
ました a というフェイス来てくださった皆様本当にありがとうございました
僕はですね普段動画ばかり作ってて皆さんに会いに
次回からない何かすごい大変だったんですけどもみなさまとあえて僕はとても嬉しかっ
たです本当に皆様で入ってよかったです
ありがとうございました
がまあ僕基本的に毎日とは言ってないんですけどもなるべく毎日動画だしててその3
日間も朝から夜まで全部イベントで動画を作る暇もなかった中
3日間毎日動画を出すことができましたけどねほんとにもう
ua ブーンまで頑張ったと思う自分で言うのもなんでおかしいんですけどで本当に
頑張った結果3日間ほぼ寝てません朝から夜までがイベントでほぼ時間がない何かどう
やって動画を出したかと言いますと
どうぞをたくさん取っておいて編集に時間がかかるとで朝から夜まで全部イベント出た
後に
夜にベッドの終わってその女郎から次の日の朝までの間に何と編集をしておくという
生活が3日間続いて
丸と目の前がぼやけるぐらいちょっと疲れておりますないけど
かけがえのない時間を過ごせたと思います本当にみなさんありがとうございますでもう
今多分キーのいたらもう寝ちゃうぐらいなんですよ割台まぁちょっと滅多にないくらい
限界レベルに疲れがきててもうちょっと
自分が誰が誰だかわかんなくなってきたから疲れているんですけども
もうほぼ頭も回らない体は動かないけど限界の状態で今から友達を笑わせてみようと
思いますもう細かい技術は入りません今まで行ってきた本能的な知性と感性
生まれ持った選手で留めだけを生かしてちょっと今から友達を限界な状態の時に笑わせ
てみようと思いますではいってきます
滅多に見れませんよあと疲れてるから
あんまり決めしないでー
深く考えないで見てね以降4 a
他は知らせ
[音楽]
宜しくお願今回は
笑ったら
負けです
いいですねっ
持って
[音楽]
par
う版頑張るん
うわあああああ
ああああああああ
ええええええ
任天堂の新しい商品ですん
だれくるぐらい待ってなんてちょっとは他の力ではランサー
ようなツイートダメ
音声どうぞ
[音楽]
よし
はーはっはっはっは
ああああああ
[音楽]
はーふわぁ
me
teame
car
me あった
er 4勝4シャイアー
[拍手]